so what we're seeing in portland with
these riots
and uh they've actually chilled out
quite a bit so uh
i don't know if you guys have been i
think we've all been kind of following
what's going on and for those who are
listening
the the people in portland uh last night
dance party that's awesome that's it and
i'm like i'm like bravo everybody that's
amazing thank you for the dance party i
reported on it i said it was really
great you did that and i wondered where
are the extremists
they've been out there for a hundred and
something nights and all of a sudden the
past couple of nights everything kind of
just you know dance party that it's
federal right the feds came in the feds
came in they deputized the cops and then
they patched up the the the terrorists
it's time
plucked them out and now all that's left
is
a bunch of dance a dance party all right
so so
what ends up happening with the with
like these district attorneys and these
other jurisdictions
is that you have you have a big group of
regular people
and then you have some extremists the
extremists start the fight but they tell
everybody to wear all black
so when the cops were going in and
trying to arrest like they'll see
someone throw an explosive right
the cops will run in and grab the person
and say we don't know if this is the
person who threw that because they all
are wearing the same thing yeah
so they charge them with interfering
with a peace officer or something like
that or disorderly the d.a then says
so you don't actually know what they did
i can't charge them with this
free to go i would have a similar thing
where if i would drop a piece of food on
the ground i'd look around and if i
couldn't find it i'd just pick up one
little piece of trash and throw it away
oh that was like one for one that's
right
well so what you're saying is you're
violating the rights of that garbage i
did it was not in fact your garbage
no but but uh the point is the tactic of
antifa is to confuse the police and
become impossible to down how do you get
around that they tried charging them
with conspiracy in in dc
in 2017 the ones that would get in the
way so the cops just arrested all of
them
and then charged them all with
conspiracy okay that's heavy-handed
yeah i don't know i mean if you're just
out there well if you're out there
wearing black
you're loud what you're doing but no
that's right it seems like you're if
you're
signing up for something look let's say
you go for a jog and you're wearing
black sweatpants
or like let's say you're wearing like an
adidas track suit and like in a hoodie
or something
you're gonna look very very similar to
the rest of them yeah and so they're
going to arrest everybody and they're
going to say no look how he's dressed
he's in on it
you can't you can't arrest somebody
you're not supposed to wear black right
because
in dc it was during the day yeah you
can't arrest everybody that's not the
way to do it they arrested like 200
something people
and then the charge is all basically
look some people pled guilty
pleaded guilty they were like it's
easier they thought if they were going
to get in trouble
it's going to be bad to the cops they
the state ended up getting a handful of
these people
but then everyone else stood their
ground and said no and then the charges
all just got dismissed
because the judge did the same thing
it's like you you're you have no
evidence this person did anything wrong
you can't just because they're wearing a
hoodie and the argument from
the prosecutors i don't know if this is
our exact argument but the general idea
is
if they tell everyone we're all black so
that we get away with crimes
you're aiding and abetting all these
crimes and you pre-planned it there was
a guy
i saw a video where he was like we don't
want to record anyone doing crimes
and then the guy went up and like did a
crime or something
that sounds right don't worry have you
seen that video of the
the kids getting arrested at one of the
protests and they're like crying and
freaking out no i don't think so
the girl was wearing a shirt that said
be gay do crimes oh my god
it's like it's like a meme thing like do
crimes it's like you say something and
say do crimes it's like dude
they don't understand what it means to
do crimes like
they they've not grown up in any world
with any kind of discipline
and so what happens is it's crazy
you grow up you grow up in the city and
and you actually see like the inner city
stuff
and you see some dude running on the
street full speed and the cops tackle
them and then throw them in a police car
you're like wow i don't want that to
happen
but if you grow up never seeing it what
do you get you get these videos of these
women in new york going or
effing what to the cops that was great
and the cop grabs her and just pulls
right like
just justice vindication seriously you
know if it's a bad law
then i think it's your duty as a as a
sovereign human to violate it and cause
a crime which is crazy but if it's a
vicious like
immoral law that some corrupt government
put into place
you kind of have to maybe it's a crime
maybe that's too absolute though
nazi germany for instance they had
horrible laws absolutely that people had
to
violate and became criminals just and
and there's a really good point about uh
there's like a protest sign and the left
loves to prop these things up
where it was like uh the the nazis were
acting
legally and the people who were helping
the jews escape were the criminals
so absolutely like that yeah just like
law does not mean morality by any man
by any means but i say absolute because
maybe sometimes there's unjust laws and
the appropriate response is like
tactful uh yeah legislation in your
legislation
yeah like like something dumb you know
like yeah i don't know there could be
some dumb law about
uh computer programs and like labor
rights or something it's like jaywalking
like if you think i guess the challenge
there why i say it's you got to be
careful about how absolute you go is
because some people are going to be like
i believe that taxes are
you know oh yeah like making their own
moral justification and then they go and
do something crazy right
yeah so important i believe i have a
right to you know then they
insert nonsensical psychotic i guess
it's why we put so much faith in our law
makers
and why having these almost like clowns
dance around and and
in office for 40 years disassociated
from the populace
is so detrimental to people's psyche
right now and why they're out there
they don't know what if they should yeah
some of the a lot of these leftists
think that the logic you just said they
have
they have to stop these unjust laws so
they're going out and they're throwing
explosives and starting fires
and attacking people because they think
they're in nazi germany what laws are
the unjust that you know i mean
they they literally think police
shouldn't exist oh that's no okay that's
extreme right right but but
imagine of a larger people saying it's
unjust to have police incarcerating
people
so they go and like abolish the police
and they need to study mercenary warfare
before we invented standing arms
the mercenaries would be hired to cause
chaos they would and then when the war
would end
they'd go cause more chaos so they'd get
hired by the other side to go stop it
and it was that sounds like um the
premise to
actually it sounds like the premise to
iron man one and three oh wow yeah have
you guys seen
you've seen them both i saw the first
one yeah the first one is
uh the the the bad guy was the iron
monger
uh obadiah he's dealing weapons to the
the the terrorists oh yeah so you know
so that he can get what he wants or
whatever but then he's also
making weapons you know for the united
states so he's double dealing
and and tony's like are we double
dealing but then you literally have in
iron man 3
the bad guy aldrich killian is like i'll
have the president
and the world's most powerful terrorist
i'll own the war on terror i'm like
that's like the same plot from the first
one with a different villain oh how
cheap
yeah yeah his name is killian too it's
like so
uh you've got people who think they're i
i would
this is a serious challenge you know you
know what you know the ethical conundrum
is
that if the nazis won then
everything they did would would be
called just is that nuts it's scary
it's very scary and like what world are
we living in did our ancient ancestors
win and they were the bad guys bro do
you know about the japanese
uh experiments in world war ii a little
bit and we we just what was it operation
paper clip
you know about that that's when we
brought a bunch of scientists from like
nazi germany and
us to continue their work so we're we're
we're
more than willing to be like well take
all of what you got we need smart people
science first
dude the what's that unit in japan uh
741 was that what 471 was that what it
was
yeah they would like take someone's arm
and put it through
a hole in like a crate or something into
like a refrigerator or something
to watch it freeze in real time to see
what would happen oh
yeah dude jeez they did really creepy
this is just the stuff we know about
right since matt since radio and
television were invented like before
that before
oh it was way worse it was like sure the
wheel the way they would torture and
execute people and then like 400 years
ago
you should look up the wheel it's such a
digital okay so
tie people to iraq and then break their
arms exactly so if you're interested in
that okay i was totally wrong about the
number of the unit it's unit 731
731 yeah and then yeah so much uh so
much torture
it's amazing that we're we have peace at
all like people don't understand peace
is the anomaly yeah i was reading that
a lot of what we know about hypothermia
we only know because of that
was it 731 one yeah like we took their
research
and so it benefited us but the human
exploitation and experimentation and all
that stuff happened
so anyway look i think a reasonable
human being hears a story of like
scientists putting humans into like
torture devices to watch their bones
break
and we're like yo that's evil stuff or
they're like you know taking people for
no
reason other than their ethnic
background and loading them on trains
and we're like
dude and then you have police who are
like please stop burning down the
neighborhood and they're like
we live in a fascist dictatorship no
it'd be a hard job to be a cop i'm i've
never been a cop i don't know if you
guys have i mean i don't think either
you guys have ever been cops
so go out there and be afraid someone's
gonna fire on you to shoot you basically
if you if you don't bro shoot them first
a cop got shot in the head in vegas
when he's parallel this is crazy yeah
what a crazy job and i don't want robots
to do it because the robot is gonna be
on automatic
and it's gonna be like you are guilty or
whatever i don't know though i don't
know though
because the robot's not gonna have to
use lethal force because the robot's not
not alive indestructible i mean not
indestructible but the robot
doesn't need to fear for its own
destruction that's a good point it can
be repaired inside a person
so the robot can have only less lethals
and be effective that's a good point
however a robot's not going to chase
down a dude hopping fences well
the right robot might have you seen
those boston dynamics
dude i do not want to live in that world
but what if it's only for just
no no no no no it's going to turn around
and be like it's going to
recognition you and it's going to go ian
crossland you haven't watched i didn't
mean to drop the pain
you fj walked for the last time yeah one
time i was in la i was driving down a
hill at night
and it was raining and i was moving fast
down the hill and the light turned
yellow
and i i hit my brakes but i was gonna
skid and i didn't know if someone was
coming behind me
so i just it turned red and i just went
through it because it was the safe thing
to do if i'd slammed on my brakes and
someone came behind me it would have
been an accident robot cop would arrest
you
the camera took a picture of my car and
sent me a ticket but a cop wouldn't have
a cop would have been like you did the
right thing
and i've i've had a i had a friend who
got a ticket in the mail
for blowing a red light and they show
you the picture of you doing it and it
was like basically a comic of someone
doing a a legal right turn on red
it was like you see the car pull up stop
and then like the next panel is just
waiting and then it's turning to the
right yeah it's like clerical error
alone is yeah
i mean humans have clerical error and
that's kind of what there's these
revolutions about right think about
what happens if like so if the robot has
no lethal capabilities
and it can catch you that might not be a
bad thing stunning because
what's the word maybe not it's asleep
but it might not need to do those things
it can just grab you and you're like i
can't get off this robot and i can't
carry it it's too heavy
what do i do bone trying to get away i
mean but you might be right i mean if
you do
just subduction is that the word
subduing simple subduction
yeah that sounds right maybe i mean kind
of right kind of wrong
i'm i'm you know so i guess the issue is
maybe it does make sense and uh maybe it
can be done better
because like i mentioned it you know if
the robot breaks
okay so it's it's vandalism so cops
could be in a vr helmet
like how drone pilots are comparing
commanding their
ai robots have you seen uh you you've
seen those things with like a cradle
where you strap on a harness and then
you stand to the vr gaming rig oh no
it's get one and you wear these special
shoes
and you're in a bowl and you when you
run your feet slide yes
oh yeah i love those so the cops have so
basically like like the movie surrogates
i haven't seen it so like in sura gets
everybody lays
in this bed and then connects their
brain to a fake robot version of
themselves
and that's it's or maybe even like ghost
in the shell no that's still human
human acting like the problem with like
a robot
is that you're gonna be like on your way
to your job and you don't have money for
bail
and you really need this interview and
the robot's going to look at you and go
you blew the red light ian and you go i
i'm i'm walking
submit i'm i'm not driving i didn't bro
submit submit and you're like
be way it could be way worse
i know humans we would have to be free
software we would have to know the code
on demand you would have to be able to
look at the robot's code like show me
your badge number show me your code to
make sure it's not doing something
faulty
the robot could maybe just hold you
until a human officer showed up and then
you saw the problem of the human officer
being like look i don't know what
happened i have to review the file
you're under arrest
and then what if the what robot
malfunctions and it accuses you of like
some really crazy crime
no that's dystopia but i guess they
could review footage and then have to
prove it
yeah otherwise you get cut loose
immediately you know what this could be
like there there is a net benefit to the
surveillance state that people have no
talk about
sure that so i was reading i was reading
this thing on reddit about
uh how i think it was on reddit how how
they catch serial killers
what was i watching oh so i was i think
i was watching sherlock the the bbc one
that shows pretty good actually i'm
gonna watch more that's a benedict
yeah that's good benedict cumberbatch
that's great and they said like how do
you cut how would you go about catching
a serial killer today and they said
what people don't realize is that it's
actually really easy
to i don't know i think i was watching
it was i was watching red dragon
oh yeah we just watched that yeah yeah
yeah and they were saying why am i
watching these sugar color things i
don't know about that
question i just watched dexter no i'm
just kidding no they said basically
when there's a car spotted they just
punch it in and they can pull up
surveillance footage from a lot of
things that are like networked and
facial recognition
and then they immediately are like oh
look we found out who was there and
here's our suspect
fingerprints in general man that was a
huge leap forward in law enforcement
that i think for the most part has done
a lot of good for society
criminals are caught you know that
otherwise would have just been in and
out think about what the surveillance
state can actually end up doing
good i ultimately think the surveillance
state is going to be really bad because
i i think
there's certain laws that have to be
broken and i'll talk about in a second
but uh
think about it this way we have we hear
all these stories about innocent people
getting charged and innocent people
going on death row
imagine if a dude you know the cops
showed us out and say the description
you know of this murder it's they said
you are the suspect and the guy goes
dude i wasn't anywhere near there
i was at work that day and they go oh
yeah well we're going to check the
surveillance network
okay it looks like you were right sorry
waste your time sir and they leave
so it can prove innocence it can people
are worried about it because
you'll be like found guilty or caught
and i'm kind of like
there there is something to be concerned
about because we never get rid of laws
right that's the big problem right so
easy to make them relative to getting
rid of them
so then how do you actually get rid of
these laws i don't know you have to
repeal them
people have to break them sometimes or
go yeah go to a state next to where it's
illegal and do it
until the people are pressured to change
it where they are but if it's a federal
thing then how do you do that
marijuana is a really good example yeah
i was talking to
this hacker his name's moxie marlon
spike and he explained to me the problem
with mass surveillance and a lack of
secrecy and privacy is that people need
to break the
law to know when laws should be broken
or should be repealed
and he said marijuana is the best
example if people weren't breaking the
law by smoking it
then how would they know they wanted it
to be legal it's a good point so the
problem then is not about whether you
think marijuana should be legal or not
legal it's that
uh illegal or not is that we keep making
new laws
and when do we get rid of them my
favorite is there's like their books
about wacky laws i don't know if you've
ever seen them
uh a little bit it's like you can't take
a shower on tuesdays
yeah you know if it's sunny out you
can't tie your goat up to stop signs
that makes sense though there was one
where i was like you can't make a cherry
pie and put it on your windowsill on
sunday afternoon oh because it's
tempting
like it's like all the churchgoers
that's you don't want to like what
happened to me
yeah like what what happened to make
these laws require these laws are
interesting to me because you know
there's really interesting stories
behind all of them
like why can't you put a cherry pie on
your windowsill why can't you tie a goat
to a stop sign
and it's it's probably some law that was
created just to appease like an angry
old lady
probably like like her her neighbor kept
putting pies karen
yeah and her neighbor was attracting the
local kids yep so she went to like the
local
mayor and it was like these kids keep
coming because she's putting her pies on
she knew somebody that
yeah she had connections and the mayor's
like okay how about you can make your
pies put them on the windowsill but not
on sunday because we're gonna go to
church and you don't want the kids
coming around
now there are these crazy laws there's
like there's a lot of the
laws that are crazy are about like water
conservation oh like you can't take a
bath on this day at this time
like that whoa and it's like we never
got rid of those laws oh okay
but i really i that's this is what
judges are for like if a cop
kicked in your door it's like aha taking
a bath on sunday at 4pm oh snap
jimmy lock him up the judge is going to
be like what is this there's some weird
federal laws
on the books right now like uh ancient
you know espionage was it
is it the espionage act is that one
that's like this old from like the 1780s
the logan act how old is that seventeen
hundred seven like seventeen hundred and
it's it's one of the i don't know much
about it but
it's that you can't represent you can't
so this is what michael got michael
flynn
yeah and it's a bunk law because it's
never been used you
can't go to a foreign country and claim
to represent the us
the law was made because we didn't have
phones
right if you if like if you went to
egypt and you like went to a state
building and you said you were like a
diplomat
they'd be like they pick up their phone
and be like no you're not is
is ian cross on a diplomat what are you
doing here
it's that simple there's no there's no
real concern about it you get charged on
the logan
i i'm not sure if the logan applies to
private citizens i think it does right
i'm not that's sure i don't think the
issue is but like a congressman couldn't
go to egypt and be like i'm here on
behalf of the united states
i think that's it that's right okay
because because they're not
actually yeah i think they're not there
on behalf of the united states they'd be
there
like you know what that's a good
question actually
i know that uh yeah maybe maybe it has
to do with
you're you're there as a part of a
delegation that's confirmed and assigned
versus you going as a private citizen
and negotiating
there are some concerns about it like if
trump is negotiating uh some deal we'll
say iran
and then a senator flies to iran and
then undercuts that deal
there's issues there but like the logan
act is one of these laws that says like
doesn't really make sense anymore
yeah because they can make a phone call
if they know you're a senator
you don't have to say you're a senator
to go talk to some israeli businessman i
mean
so are you automatic just just by nature
of your title are you
if you dm something on twitter is it
exactly with the internet like
cross-border communication is just so
natural now
so any anyway though back back to the
the point before we go off into
you know the stratosphere deep space
how do we what do we do to get rid of
all these laws should we have like a law
a lauded yeah and we go through just go
through all the lines
i'm going to spin the ufo for that
because we should do it
and smash that like button i love it you
like that word as much as i do
no but for real yeah we've got uh uh
it's it seems like we only ever stack
laws up
very much could you imagine a robot that
enforced every single law
it would be a goodness pure insanity
that would be a really excellent it'll
probably have conflicting laws
that it couldn't compete yeah dude yeah
definitely you'd fried throwback
especially when you do federal law and
state law
definitely i am federal they they
probably
oh man well i mean that kind of exists
today but could you imagine like
dea robots encountering state police
robots
robot warfare and then the robots are
just fighting in the street because like
the laws are different i think criminals
are running around think about it this
way
with the kind of chaos we've seen where
the states are going up against the
federal government right now
like say oregon for instance where the
attorney general sued the federal
government
and they're saying like you can't do
these things here we had we had a d.a
in philly say that he would arrest feds
if they came to enforce the law in
in philly or something like that so what
would happen if the state robots are
programmed and they're like don't allow
anyone else to enforce the law
federals are not allowed to be here then
atf for robots or like
federal protective service robots show
up and then the robots like
i'm imagining those boston dynamics
things and they like run
and they see you and they are like
citizen you are in violation of
you know city ordinance unlawful
assembly declared you're freaking me out
and then the other robot runs up and
goes
you know like uh law enforcement unit
7369 federal
234 you are in violation and they both
start spouting code at each other yeah
and then they both just grab each other
and then they start
just unscrewing each other and then one
climbs on top of the other and now
there's two robots and they're running
around oh it's crazy i think you're
right because if there's bad laws in a
robot it has to enforce that that is
bad news humans are like i know it's bad
i'm not gonna enforce it like you see
cops they were like
in theory in theory i don't know about
that okay maybe it may be right though
maybe it's actually like an anomaly
when a human disenforces a a bad law
i mean you've got these cops in virginia
saying the sheriffs we're not going to
invoice
enforce these these gun control measures
you know they're violations of the
second amendment
and they started setting up these
sanctuary jurisdictions
that's the police being like i will not
cross that line
but if we did robots then you could just
be like here's the law up here's the law
update and then you're like
it's like a gigabyte file of all these
crazy yeah
yeah so this could be like how they do
plane manuals
because instead of carrying really big
thick books around now pilots just have
these tablets that they carry with them
and before every single flight the
manual for the whole plane is updated
and they can look through it if they
need to
so imagine like you're standing next to
a robot and you're like
uh you're like robot inquiry and the
robot goes yes citizen
would it be illegal if i uh crossed the
street right here no you're okay thank
you and then i'll send it blinks a light
downloading new laws
oh no and then you cross the street and
go stop citizen you have violated the
law and then you're like wait what
that'd be cool because the robots would
never get tired of answering your
questions
and they wouldn't get frustrated and if
you could be like at any time tell me
the law they would have it for you
i actually think it might be cool to
have robot cops but uh
because i think it would reduce the
amount of it would actually reduce the
amount of physical harm that comes to
people
like humans make mistakes too robots are
mistaken like they get scared robots
don't get scared
and so the robot but also that the
robot's gonna be like there's no fear of
lethal
like lethal force so you could be a
criminal running with a gun and the
robot's going to be faster than you
it's going to be able to run longer
you're not it's going to subdue you it's
going to
it's going to have connections to like
helicopter it's going to ignore it can
see you from the helicopter
so like it doesn't you know it doesn't
track you easier with like
stuff i agree with you man i'm all about
using technology to help solve problems
the challenge i guess is like we already
said though the laws get out of hand
right you know what i mean right yeah
and
sometimes you know what to be fair
though maybe we'll get to that point
where we'll create
some good ai that can have better
judgment one of the really interesting
things about ai and judgment right now
is uh self-driving cars so one of the
biggest problems with self-driving cars
is that
somebody has to program whether the car
crashes into a grandmother or a baby oh
that's wild
yeah yup so i don't know if you guys
have heard about this
yeah so basically when a human is
driving a car
and then all of a sudden old lady
stumbles out in front of the car
you're like oh no and then you have a
split second and it's like if i keep
going forward
old lady goes flying if i veer left i
will crash into a tree and die
someone so you choose and if you hit the
old lady
like you might get some kind of charge
it might be considered an accident you
might not get in trouble
you'll live if you try and avoid the old
lady and you die you made the choice
and everyone makes a choice you know
based on their own morality or whatever
someone's got to program into these
self-driving cars which one to kill
and then does it the driver or the does
it go to like the car company
have to cover the the legal
ramifications
i don't think so i think the insurance
company the insurance company so if your
car
automated car kills somebody it's not in
your hands it would it would be would
you get in a car
that told you outright if this car
encounters any
potential uh like lethal in uh fatal
instance
it will sacrifice you no yeah i wouldn't
either
hi welcome to tesla automatic driving
car if we crash
we'll kill you it's like no i'll tell
you i would rather first
quite this yeah i'd rather oh gosh what
have you done i bumped the table no
you broke that you've got the magic
touch you could no you have to do it
knock the ufo off
you just gotta just kind of center it
okay anyway let's let's do this let's
let's we talked enough about robots no
we haven't talked
let's talk about what's going on with
the oath keepers man oh thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time